Factoring the expression on the left gives us x plus 45 plus x minus 10 times x
minus 10 is less than or equal to 0. So our 2 critical values for x then that
are going to split up our number line are negative 45 and 10. Our interval then,
that we get from these critical numbers are x is less than or equal to negative
45. Negative 45 is less than or equal to x, which is less than or equal to 10,
and 10 is less than or equal to x. Here, we include the critical values in each
of these intervals, because we have a less than or equal to sign, not just a
less than sign. We know that if x equals either of these critical values, the
expression will actually equal 0 and that means it definitely would satisfy the
inequality. So we want to test these intervals. We want to include those
critical values in each of them.